♪ ♪
>> Greg: YESTERDAY ON "THE
VIEW," STORMY DANIELS AND HER
LAWYER REVEALED THE SKETCH OF
THE MAN WHO ALLEGEDLY THREATENED
HER.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> TO YOUR RECOLLECTION, IS THAT
THE PERSON THAT THREATENED YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SEVEN YEARS AGO.
>> YOU REMEMBERED TO THAT
DETAIL.
LOOKS LIKE AN ACTOR, SORT OF.
>> THAT'S WHY HE'S TURNED OUT TO
ME.
I THOUGHT HE WAS SORT OF
HANDSOME.
WHEN I SAW HIM WHEN I WAS
PARKING, OH, THAT IS SOMEBODY'S
HUSBAND.
>> Greg: THE PRESIDENT TODAY
RESPONDED TO THIS SAYING A
SKETCH YEARS LATER ABOUT A
NONEXISTENT MAN, TOTAL CON JOB,
PLAYING THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA FOR
FOOLS BUT THEY KNOW IT.
HIS TWEET LINKED TO A COMPARISON
IN WHICH A TWITTER USER THINKS
THERE'S A COMPARISON BETWEEN THE
MYSTERY MAN IN STORMY'S HUSBAND.
FOR THE MEDIA GETS ON THEIR HIGH
HORSE, BE AWARE EVERYTHING A
MEDIA MOUTHPIECE IS DOING THE
VERY SAME THING.
THE SKETCH INVITES COMPARISON.
AND IN A CIRCUS LIKE THIS, A
CIRCUS MADE MORE ABSURD EVERY
DAY BY MEDIA AND LEGAL
HYSTERICS, IT'S ANOTHER MAD
ATTRACTION TO CHALLENGERS ANY
DECORUM WE HAVE LEFT.
AFTER STORMY SHOWS UP IN COURT
AND REVEALS THE SKETCH ON A
MORNING GABFEST.
IT'S HARD TO TAKE ANY OF IT
SERIOUSLY, ESPECIALLY AS THE
PRESIDENT MAKES POTENTIALLY
HISTORIC PROGRESS WITH
NORTH KOREA.
WHO IS THE GUY IN THE SKETCH?
THIS GUY OR THAT GUY OR THIS
GUY.
I DON'T KNOW.
I AM BEGINNING TO THINK NO ONE
ELSE DOES EITHER.
I HAVE TO READ, MICHAEL
AVENATTI, IS THAT HOW YOU SAY
IT?
STORMY'S HUSBAND'S LAWYER AS
WELL.
RESPONDED TO TRUMP'S TWEET AND I
WANT TO READ THEM.
"IN MY EXPERIENCE THERE IS
NOTHING BETTER IN LITIGATION
THAT HAVING A COMPLETELY
UNHINGED, UNDISCIPLINED OPPONENT
PRONE TO SHOOTINGS OF THE FOOT
FOOT.
ALWAYS LEADS TO BIG PROBLEMS
LIKE NEW CLAIMS.
SECOND TWEET.
AS THE WALLS CLOSE AND REALITY
SETS IN FOR THE MOST DAMAGING
WITNESSES, NO LONGER PROTECTED.
ALL RIGHT, I HAVE TO --
>> Kimberly: NEWS THAT
AVENATTI IS ON ANOTHER NETWORK
SAYING HE'S GOING TO ADD A
DEFAMATION CASE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT.
THIS IS A MEME.
PEOPLE HAVE TOM BRADY,
KATO KAELIN.
>> Dana: I SAW ONE OF YOU.
>> Greg: I DID TOO.
THAT WASN'T FUNNY.
I'M NOT THAT GOOD LOOKING.
>> Kimberly: IT SHOULD BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY IF SOMEBODY
THREATENED HER AND SAID YOU ARE
NOT TO COOPERATE, INTIMIDATION,
HARASSED HER TO THE POINT WHERE
SHE FELT SHE NEEDED TO BE
SILENCED.
HOWEVER, NEVER THE LESS, NOW
THEY ARE ON THE VIEW AND
LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
ALL OVER THE INTERNET, EVERYBODY
MAKING COMPARISONS.
A VARIETY PEOPLE SAY IT LOOKS
LIKE THEM.
FRANKLY BECAUSE IT DOES RESEMBLE
SO MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE, AS A
FORMER PROSECUTOR, I WILL TELL
YOU IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR POSITIVE IDENTIFICATION.
IT COULD BE ANYBODY.
LET'S JUST PROSECUTE ANYBODY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IT IS RIFE WITH PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFICATION,
REASONABLE DOUBT, LOOKS LIKE
THIS PERSON.
ARE YOU SURE?
THE PASSAGE OF TIME, INABILITY
TO MAKE UP POSITIVE I.D.?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
>> Dana: IS IMPOSSIBLE THE
MATERIAL THEY SEIZED AND MICHAEL
COHEN'S RAID AND HIS EMAILS
WOULD LEAD THEM BACK TO THIS
MYSTERIOUS ACTOR PERSON?
>> Kimberly: YOU KNOW WHAT,
DANA?
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
IF THERE WAS THE IDENTITY OF A
PERSON AND IN FACT HE WAS ACTING
IN CONCERT AS SPECIFIED FOR
SOMEONE TO GO, MAYBE BUT I DOUBT
HIS NAME WILL BE WRITTEN IN BIG
BOLD PRINT SOMEWHERE.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO HAVE I
THINK A SPECIAL, GOING THROUGH
ALL THE DOCUMENTS TO MAKE SURE
ONLY WHAT YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO TO
UPHOLD THE ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
THERE COULD BE A LOT OF VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN THERE
THAT AREN'T PERTINENT.
>> Greg: IT IS SO GOOD WE HAVE
A PROSECUTOR HERE.
I WILL NEED HELP LATER.
JUAN, DO YOU HAVE A THEORY?
EVERYONE IS ADDING TO THIS,
GUESS WHO THE GUY IS IF THE GUY
EXIST.
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
A PUBLICITY STUNT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK KIMBERLY IS RIGHT, IT
PEOPLE ARE BEING INTIMIDATED OR
HARASSED, WE SHOULDN'T DISMISS
IT.
>> Kimberly: EVEN IF THERE IS
A PASSAGE OF TIME.
IS PC EVAN WHY IS THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING ABOUT IT?
I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
DO.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEN HE SAID IT DIDN'T HAPPEN,
SO LET IT BE.
IT WAS A GOOD STRATEGY ON HIS
PART BUT NOW HE'S TWEETING ABOUT
HER INTO ME IT'S LIKE A TAWDRY
DISPLAY.
>> Greg: IT IS.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT CAN HELP HIMSELF.
I THINK WE ARE BEYOND THAT
POINT.
I GET THAT SEX SELLS.
15 MINUTES HAS TO BE UP SOON.
IT'S ABOUT A NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT THAT ALLEGEDLY BROKEN.
A COURT SHOULD FAST-TRACK IT.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO GET A
JUDGMENT OR THEY ARE GOING TO
SETTLE.
OR GO TO ARBITRATION.
BUT WHEN YOU PILEUP THESE
STUNTS, THE SKETCH TO THE PHOTO
OF THE LIE DETECTOR TEST TO THE
NATIONWIDE STRIP CLUB TOUR TO
THIS GUYS ALL OVER EVERY SINGLE
CABLE OUTLET, AND THEN WHAT ELSE
ARE THEY DOING?
FIRST OF ALL, THE LAWYER IS A
HIGHLY PAID DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY
WHO HAS REPRESENTED THOUSANDS OF
DEMOCRATS.
TEED HIM UP WITH A PUBLICITY
SEEKING PORN STAR.
NOT SAYING THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
INACCURATE.
THEY GO HAND-IN-HAND.
YOU HAVE THE MEDIA USHERING THEM
ALONG.
IT'S A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
THEY DON'T ASK HER CHALLENGING
QUESTIONS.
THEY NEVER DEBATE HER.
THEY TAKE EVERYTHING SHE SAYS AS
FACT.
IT'S BEYOND THE POINT OF NO
RETURN.
IT'S ABOUT A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION.
BERNIE SANDERS SETTLED HER
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION FOR
$14,000 BECAUSE HE ACCEPTED
DONATIONS FROM AUSTRALIA.
THIS IS THE EXACT SAME TYPE OF
VIOLATION.
THEY RAIDED THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER'S OFFICE OVER THIS?